ما حدا بيعرف فينا شيء خالص خالص هنا
بجنديرس شمالي سوريا حيث النصيب الاكبر من
الكارثه المتطوعون من اهالي البلده كان
وحدهم من جابها هول الزلزال اليومين قبل
انضمام فرق الانقاذ قليله العدد شحيحه
المعدات
بالعصي بالبواري ايش نلاقي قدامنا بنعزل
طالعنا عايشين طالعنا ميتين
ضلينا لثاني يوم لحتى هون
اجا الدفاع المدني اجوا اجوا العالم
تساعدنا في جنديرس قصه البحث عن الناجين
تاخذ معنى اخر
سامر الذي انقذ العشرات منذ اربعه ايام
انهكه التعب لكن انامله لم تتوقف عن البحث
فشخص عزيز عليه تحت هذا الركام رفيق دربه
وابن حارته المدمره ما يزال في عداد
المفقودين اول بنايه وصل عليها هو البنايه
اللي ساكن فيها رفيقي رفيقي اسمه علي اول
ما وصلت
وارجع فقط لا غير
ضلينا نبحث لحد الان
[تصفيق]
متطوعوه جنديرس لا يحتاجون الى قوائم
المفقودين فهم يعرفون من قضى نحبه ومن
ينتظر وهذا الجهد المتواصل بالنسبه اليهم
هو الواجب اتجاه الاهل والوفاء قبل
التضامن علمنا اعز رفقاتي ابو قلب الطيب
والحنون
يعني ما فينا نقول شيء غير حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل
عبد القادر خربوش العربيه